joe biden is also saying that he would
like to do that most important thing to
be clear about is we have to change i
believe we have to codify
roe v wade in the law and the way to do
that is to make sure that congress votes
to do that and if the filibuster gets in
the way it's like voting rights it
should be we provide an exception for
this
for the except the
requiring exception of the filibuster
for this action to deal with the supreme
court decision okay mumbling stumbling
buffoon joe biden it's just it's just
incredible that we're all pretending
that this guy's running the country it's
absolutely incredible uh interestingly
uh in
2005 now joe biden's been a part of
public life for roughly 280 years that's
longer than the country has been here
but in 2005
he did not want to end the filibuster
i'm shocked
we should make no mistake
this nuclear option is ultimately an
example of the arrogance of power
it is a fundamental power grab
by
the majority party
a fundamental
power grab but joe that's what you're
doing right now that's what aoc and
elizabeth warren want to do why would
you guys want a fundamental power grab
your guys are the good guys you're for
the people
oh you're not going to believe this guys
we found video of democrats over the
years defending the filibuster they want
to make this country into a banana
republic where if you don't get your way
you change the rules the legislative
filibuster should stay there and i i
will personally uh resist efforts to get
rid of them i'm committed to never
voting to change the legislative
filibuster that would be the end of the
senate it raises problems that are more
damaging than the problems exist you
cannot change the rules
in the middle of the game because you do
not like the outcome you're going to
throw the entire congress in the chaos
and nothing will get done change the
rules in midstream
to wash away 200 years of history
nothing at all will get done ideologues
in the senate
want to turn what the founding fathers
called the cooling saucer of democracy
into the rubber stamp of dictatorship if
you don't have 60 votes yet it just
means you haven't done enough advocacy
and you need to work a lot harder
you really need to understand these are
horrible human beings there's no other
way to put it i don't think they should
be well some of them probably should be
jailed because i'm sure they're up to
illegal stuff but i don't think that we
should show up at their houses i don't
think we should be publicly intimidating
them or anything else what we should be
doing is obviously exposing their
hypocrisy we should be mocking them we
should be voting them out of office but
you need to understand they will do
anything for power it does not mean that
republicans are so great republicans
fail all the time and there's an awful
lot of pet republicans out there the liz
cheney's mitt romney's okay they go on
msnbc they get pat pet on the head and
they get a feta cookie or something
republicans do things wrong all the time
they blow up budgets all of that stuff
but
at least within the sort of roughly
conservative republican
libertarian worldview there is a sense
of limiting power there is a sense of
individual rights the basic quest there
on that right side of the aisle is we we
all are different we want to limit power
to some degree they may fail at it most
of the time but at least there is a
guiding principle there somewhere right
and the government should not do
everything these people want the
government to do every freaking thing
possible and it's because they're in
power and they don't want to give up
that power it's almost as if they have
some sort of liberal new world order
that they're protecting at all costs
what do you say to those families who
say listen we can't afford to pay 485 a
gallon for months if not years this is
just not sustainable
what you heard from the president today
was a clear articulation of the stakes
this is about the future of the liberal
world order and we have to stand firm
what
okay now that's uh biden's economic
advisor who of course happens to be a
former blackrock executive
surprise surprise i know it's wild the
way these people bounce around in these
things um but what somehow if we're not
at war with ukraine or giving them a
whole bunch of money or just you know
writing a blank check et cetera et
cetera and our gas prices are going up
and our inflation is going up and our
economy is being destroyed if we don't
do that then the liberal world order is
going to collapse
what are they talking about what are
they talking about i don't know what the
hell's going on in ukraine i don't think
we should be given a dime anymore and i
assure you i am not on putin's payroll i
don't think putin is a good guy i don't
think you can just invade sovereign
nations this is ridiculous and by the
way the more that they lie about
everything i think they're doing
something really twisted related to the
ukraine thing right now which is that
it's causing nobody to care at all which
is why i don't really cover it on the
show nobody really cares i care about
the human suffering and i actually know
a few people who've had to flee ukraine
and i'm doing some things on the on the
side to help at least two people uh but
but nobody cares because everyone thinks
everything that comes out of this
administration is nonsense no one thinks
giving them 40 billion dollars
unaccounted for but what we have to do
it to defend the new world order
of joe biden and these people well then
that's not a liberal world order that i
want to defend and i'm the freaking guy
who wrote the book on classical
liberalism